[Music]
who were the Vikings just saying the
word Viking elicits an image of a
notoriously violent bunch of people that
wreaked havoc across Europe in the
Middle Ages but at their core they were
explorers
hi I'm rich Burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives five
experts take a look at these Infamous
explorers whose voyages left an
indelible Mark in our imaginations We
Begin now with a look at what the term
Viking actually means
who were the Vikings
properly they should be called Norsemen
people of the North
they came from Scandinavia what is today
Denmark Sweden and Norway and they were
Fierce war-like pagans at the time that
they descended onto Europe
the specific word Viking is actually a
kind of professional label or even job
description to go on Viking means to go
on a raid avik is an inlet or a fjord
and Viking or Viking was this the name
for someone who stealthily moved his
ship close to the shore up an inlet and
then attacked the locals
Viking journeys of pillage began in the
700s and they terrorized significant
parts of Europe for two centuries when
people saw the dragon-headed ships of
the Vikings coming closer from the sea
they would be well advised to flee
the first onslaughts of the Vikings were
a terrible shock
this frightening phenomenon erupted out
of nowhere with the attack on the
monastery of lindisfadna on the
northeast coast of Britain in the year
793. it was a place where monks among
them Irish like Saint Brendan prayed and
worked peacefully after the Viking sack
of Linda swarna a chronicler wrote that
quote the pagans have contaminated God's
shrines and Spilled Out the blood of
saints around the altar they have laid
waste the house of our consolation and
in the temple of God they have trampled
underfoot the bodies of saints like dung
in the streets
soon throughout Christian lands a new
prayer was added to the Liturgy which
implored from the fury of the Norsemen O
Lord preserve us
what made the norseman's attack so
fearful was that they covered huge
distances and appeared suddenly without
warning in particular they sailed across
large expanses of open Waters without
land in sight
at a time when this was seen as kind of
crazy in Europe remember from the days
of pythius the Greek how in the
Mediterranean it was well advised to
sail hugging the coasts keeping land in
sight in case of a storm or an emergency
the Norsemen were able to challenge the
Open Sea because their culture had
special attributes a strong sailor ethos
and a maritime tradition that grew out
of the very physical environment of the
Scandinavian Peninsula it is a place
where the sea is always nearby in fjords
or inlets the Vikings were able to
Pioneer Naval raiding due to their
incredible seamanship and advanced
shipbuilding techniques
Scandinavia had a very long history of
shipbuilding dating back at least to the
Bronze Age but they had made significant
advances in the centuries right before
the Viking raids began due to the
influence of the Romans who introduced
the sale to Northern Europe
their Masterpiece was the longship a
hearty flexible and lightweight vessel
capable of dominating the coasts and
rivers of Europe
longships did rely primarily on dense
Banks of oars for propulsion but the
addition of the sale gave them the
ability to range far more widely when
conditions were right
the ability to shift easily from rowing
to sailing was enhanced by the
replacement of orlocks with ore ports
still the importance of the oars can be
gauged by the fact that long ships
contain pretty much as many oars men as
could possibly be crammed in
the largest longships could hold a
hundred men and in a society of
relatively small and isolated
settlements even one or two such vessels
could create a devastating impact
pretty much everything about these boats
made them ideal for raiding
Viking longboats were extremely flexible
and slender and they were clinker built
which means that they were constructed
of planks that overlapped each other and
were then riveted together as opposed to
the system in use elsewhere in Europe in
which planks were sawed and then joined
together
clinker-built vessels were stronger
because of the overlap and they were
made even more watertight by a caulk
composed of tarred cow's hair
longships were also very lightweight
which means that they could be
transported easily over land for example
if it was necessary to cross from One
landing point to another body of water
they also had a very shallow draft they
could maneuver in water that was only
one meter or three feet deep which made
it easy for them to come right up on
shore to let loose a raiding party
they were also able to travel up the
rivers so while they started out by
raiding islands and Coastal sites they
rather quickly graduated to traveling on
the river systems of Britain and Ireland
and Northwestern Europe
and they could penetrate hundreds of
miles inland
in addition long ships were built
symmetrically with identical front and
back ends so that they could reverse
direction as needed much the way a
subway car can face forwards or back
thus saving the need to maneuver around
in the water
the most famous thing that many people
picture when they imagine a Longboat is
a carved dragon's head on the prowl
we do have medieval illustrations of
boats with dragon's heads but it was
certainly not true that all Viking ships
had them
apparently the heads were detachable
they were intended to scare away the
spirits that were protecting your
enemies and we have later reports that
when vikings returned to Iceland they
would take the heads off when returning
to port because they didn't want to
scare away their own protective spirits
one of the most interesting questions
with regard to the Vikings is how they
navigated across the open ocean between
Scandinavia and Britain
Scholars have various opinions about
Viking navigation some Scholars maintain
that the Vikings used largely
traditional methods to navigate like
familiarity with the tides and various
landmarks
but other scholars believe that the
Vikings had access to more sophisticated
methods such as the use of devices that
would help them spot the direction of
the sun even when the sky was completely
overcast
one that has been debated is the
so-called Sunstone which is alluded to
in an Icelandic Saga
it may refer to a type of mineral
calcite that can polarize light and thus
potentially be used to find the sun even
in overcast or snowy conditions and thus
Aid navigation
we may never know but at this point the
balance of evidence lies with those who
believe the Vikings used largely their
hard-won experience of sailing in the
northern Seas to do what they did
and that makes their achievements even
more remarkable
the raid on lindisfarne shocked and
traumatized observers throughout English
Christendom
the chronicler's emotional recounting of
a miserable Devastation of heathen men
through pillage and Slaughter Echoes the
sentiments of most historical accounts
of the Vikings which paint the attackers
as bloodthirsty and violent to a
disturbing degree
seasonal rating would continue to hurry
all the kingdoms of England off and on
for most of the next century and for the
rest of the pre-norman conquest period
Scandinavians would have a regular
presence in England
but that presence was by no means
uniform different groups from different
places under different leaders would
come for very different purposes
so while English sources like the
chronicle tends to lump all
Scandinavians under a single heading
like northmen or Danish men or Heathen
Army they're actually describing a
fairly wide range of folks not all of
whom were there for pillage and
Slaughter
some it's true did come as Raiders
interested primarily in plundering
communities for their wealth and then
sailing back home with the treasure
but others came as traitors or settlers
looking for business opportunities or
land to farm driven overseas by growing
populations and land scarcity back in
Scandinavia many of them wanted to call
England their new home
first half of the 9th century saw mainly
raiding parties like the ones who sacked
lindisfarne striking centers where they
knew they could find wealth
sometimes they would completely
devastate a region on other occasions
local leaders were able to buy them off
with tribute the so-called Dane geld in
exchange for leaving them in peace
they certainly had a profound impact on
the Safety and Security of English
communities but they would attack and
then leave once they had what they came
for with little lasting influence
by the middle of the 9th century this
began to change and the rating parties
that had struck seasonally and then went
home were replaced by an army of
Conquest
the Turning Point came in 865 CE when a
massive Force landed in East Anglia led
by the sons of legendary Norse king
Ragnar Lothbrok who had been executed by
King Ella of northumbria a few years
earlier
for the first time in 865 an actual
Viking Army landed in East Anglia
intense not just on raiding but on
conquering Anglo-Saxon Britain it was
led by the unforgettably named Ivar the
Boneless
and as Remembered in English History as
the great Heathen Army it marched North
sacked Whitby captured York and seemed
all set to dominate the whole of Britain
opposition came from the kings of Wessex
Ethel red and then his brother Alfred
the Great who ruled from 871 until 899.
Alfred is the only English king ever to
be called the Great
his achievement was to prevent Viking
conquest of the whole country at one
point he was forced into hiding in the
marshlands of atholny Somerset where a
monument to him still stands
seeking shelter with an old peasant
woman according to Legend she asked him
to keep an eye on the cakes she was
baking
preoccupied by his precarious military
situation he forgot the cakes got burned
and the woman berated him only to
Discover Moments Later that she was
boxing the ears of her King
archaeological work at appleley has
shown that this was the site of an Iron
Age Fort that athenny was an island
often surrounded by flooded fields and
that a Causeway LED from it to nearby
East Ling
signs of metal working in the area also
suggest that Alfred and his followers
cast weapons there in preparation for
their counter-attack on the Vikings
another Legend has Alfred cleverly
disguised as a Minstrel spying on the
Viking Camp whatever the merits of the
legend it is true that his army won a
decisive Victory against the Viking
General guthrum at Edington in 878.
the peace agreement known as the Treaty
of Alfred and guthrum was signed in 886
as a rare survival from this period it
offers a fascinating window into
anglo-norce relations
under the terms of the treaty guthrum
agreed to accept baptism as a Christian
and Alfred stood as his Godfather
guthrum also agreed to retreat to a
territory that would become known as the
Dane law which would exist as a separate
Kingdom alongside Alfred's now enlarged
Kingdom of Wessex
it was a massive territory made up of
East Anglia northumbria and Eastern
Mercia roughly the same size as the
newly combined kingdoms of Wessex and
Western Mercia
its border ran more or less along a line
from London in the Southeast to Chester
in the northwest
within the Dane law guthrum was a
sovereign ruler not a vassal of King
Alfred and the treaty sets up laws for
both rulers to follow Alfred and
guthrum's treaty also makes it clear
that the populations will remain
separate specifying that neither
enslaved nor Freeman should be allowed
to travel into the Danish population
without permission any more than any of
them should to us
in other words guthrum subjects will
remain guthrums and Alfred subjects will
remain Alfred's no poaching of people
back and forth
but it doesn't forbid interaction and it
makes particular Provisions for trade
indicating that both Alfred and guthrum
recognize that peaceful business
exchanges across their borders would
benefit both kingdoms
the Treaty of Alfred and guthrum
established terms that enabled English
and Danes to live peacefully for many
decades
it didn't prevent violence altogether
but it did put an end to the threat of
invasion and conquest and it set up
conditions for a vibrant exchange
between the two cultures over the next
two centuries
the Scandinavians had different customs
and practices for daily life their
religion paganism was anathema to most
English Christians and their language
Norse was closely related to Old English
but the two tongues were different
enough that speakers would have to work
to understand one another
the existence of a massive population of
Scandinavian immigrants settling down
and living side by side with their
English neighbors couldn't help having
profound impacts on the development of
English language and culture
from the 790s Vikings raided Western
France and started actually settling
there in the 840s Vikings even attacked
Paris in the year 845.
the king of France finally was forced to
give the Norsemen the duchy of Normandy
from among his other territories in
exchange for their agreeing to Christian
baptism indeed the name says it all
Norman's means Norseman
the Vikings invaded Ireland from 8 30
establishing there a great trading City
Dublin they also invaded England and
took York which became the center of
Viking rule
in 1016 the Norse hero Knute the great
became king of England
the area that was under Norse rule was
called the Dane law where the Norsemen
forced the English to pay protection
money which was called Dane geld
paying Dane geld perhaps in the short
term brought security but as has been
pointed out once you pay the Dane geld
you never get rid of the Dane again
and of course coming from France those
one-time Vikings the Normans would go on
to invade England under William the
Conqueror in 1066.
while many vikings went West others went
to the east to what is today Ukraine
Russia turkey and even Iraq
There They seized local people and sold
them as slaves the word slave in English
actually comes from the ethnic name slav
the people of Eastern Europe
in Novgorod Norseman were invited to
establish a state there under their
control and they gave their name to
Russia which comes from ruse a
Scandinavian word uh apparently meaning
oarsmen
down in the Eastern Roman Empire in
Constantinople Norseman served as
mercenaries when they were not busy
attacking that City these were the famed
varangian guards of the Byzantine
emperors so from one end of Europe to
the other there were Viking Empires on
the Seas from the Pharaoh Islands to
Sicily in the Mediterranean to Russia
success of this store sort started to
Mellow the Norseman over time eventually
many vikings were domesticated and
started settling down becoming
integrated into the new areas they'd
colonized and accepting Christianity
about the time of late Erickson around
the year 1000. Leif was a convert to
Christianity and he'd been sent to
Greenland as a Christian Missionary by
King Olaf of Norway
the journeys that followed were recorded
in sagas The Saga of the greenlanders
and The Saga of Eric the Red these were
oral Traditions that were written down
around the year 1250. now they're not
completely reliable historical sources
in all particulars but they do offer
very suggestive hints about these people
and what drove them
to find this mysterious new land that
Garnet had stumbled upon Leif set out
around the year 1001 with 35 men
he wanted his father Eric to come along
on this journey because Eric was
considered the man with the best fortune
in their family the man with the best
luck but an omen intervened when Eric
fell from his horse just before the trip
and thus he declined to go
here's another clue to Viking culture
fortune or luck were tremendously valued
and sought
after sailing several hundred miles
lathe's Expedition reached land first
they encountered what they called
heluland which means flat stone land and
many people consider this might be
Baffin Island in Canada
sailing further they came to what they
called Markland the land of the forest
and it's unclear where this was perhaps
Labrador perhaps Newfoundland
then this our third land even more
attractive and they plunged ahead and
their ship ran aground The greenlander
Saga says their curiosity to see the
land was so great that they could not be
bothered to wait for the tide to come in
and Float their stranded ship instead
they jumped in a small boat and rode
ashore
there they built houses to overwinter
and they found berries or grapes and
called this place Vinland land of
berries or land of wine grapes the
ambiguity here as to which is correct
comes from the fact that the Norse
called berries and wine grapes by the
same name some Scholars actually believe
it was cranberries that they've located
in this new land
wherever Finland was the Vikings were
delighted with their new exploration
they loaded their ship with grapes and
wood and sailed back to Greenland
arriving safely from then on Leaf was
known as Leaf the lucky
Finland became a destination that Drew
subsequent explorers including as we
will see Leaf sister Freitas
but explorers would find this new land
unlike Greenland was not empty they
encountered native peoples with violent
results in about 10 10 a wealthy
Merchant named Carl cefni was drawn to
the wealth of the new world according to
Eric Saga in this Voyage Carl cephanie
took his wife goudrit and four other
women including Eric's daughter Freitas
and her husband thorvard
they apparently plan to settle for he
brought cattle along with him
I can't imagine bringing these animals
on the rough North Atlantic Crossing but
these incredible Sailors didn't even
remark on it as if it were unusual they
landed in Finland and established a camp
for the winter
in Spring the natives appeared in large
numbers coming to their summer camps by
the coast
at first both groups entered into trade
the natives wanted swords and weapons
which the Vikings refused to give them
then the natives settle for red cloth
for which they exchanged Furs and hides
when the red cloth ran out the women
brought the natives milk which they had
never tasted before
soon the natives Wanted only milk
but the two groups never trusted each
other and when a bull belonging to Karl
Stephanie came charging Out of the Woods
the natives interpreted this as an
aggressive act they fled but returned in
force prepared for battle
at first the outnumbered Vikings were
driven back and they retreated to some
Cliffs where they prepared to take a
stand
at this point Freitas came out of her
house and mocked the fleeing Vikings
according to Eric Saga she said why do
you flee from such pitiful wretches
brave men like you you should be able to
slaughter them like cattle if I had
weapons I'm sure I could fight better
than any of you
they ignored her and continued to flee
Freitas tried to follow them but she
could not keep up because she was
pregnant
the natives were closing in on her when
she came across a dead Viking with his
sword beside him she snatched up the
sword and prepared to defend herself
when the natives came rushing at her she
pulled one of her full breasts out of
her tunic faced the natives and slapped
her naked breast with the side of her
sword daring them to attack her
the natives were so surprised at this
Vision they fled back to their boats and
hurried away
Carl Stephanie and his men came over to
Freight us and praised her courage and
credited her with saving their lives
they returned to their settlement and
made plans to leave
as a saga recounts Carl Stephanie
realized that although the land was
excellent they could never live here
safely or Freed From Fear because of the
Native inhabitants
so they returned to Greenland
in this contact the natives successfully
persuaded the Europeans to stay away
and there at that point the historical
record Peters out
there may have been other later trips
for Timber but the Vikings did not
announce the news of what they had found
more broadly
other Europeans did not hear of their
discoveries from the perspective of the
Norse why would you share the news of
these resources and just invite
competitors
it would be centuries before Europeans
returned to these places until John
Cabot arrived in 1497 to claim this area
for England
eventually the Greenland colony which at
its height had some 4 000 people also
withered it was too dependent on ships
to bring supplies as the climate cooled
in the little Ice Age around the year
1200 The Colony finally died out
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria